voici le premier smartphone de Xiaomi
avec un capteur de 1 pouce et une
optique Leica c'est une petite
révolution chez Xiaomi c'est le Xiaomi
12S ultra il sort uniquement en Chine
mais il est extrêmement bluffant on a un
écran de 6,73 pouces on va de 1 à 120
Hertz 4 haut-parleurs Armanet Cardon
Dolby Atmos un dragon 8 plus xiawan
beaucoup de performances un bloc de
charge 67 watts et sauce smartphone qui
fait des super photos ce smartphone ne
sortira jamais en France mais il montre
là où on pourra aller l'année prochaine
avec le Xiaomi 13 ultra est-ce qu'un
smartphone comme ça pourrait vous tenter
marquer de moi en bas dans les
commentaires et pour tout savoir là Qtek
je vous invite à venir vous abonner